Global's Leslie Horton is both our
friend and of course the traffic
reporter at Global Calgary and she
recently called out a viewer for their
insensitive email have a look at
this just going to respond to an email
that I just got uh saying
congratulations on your pregnancy if
you're going to wear old bus driver
pants you have to expect emails like
this so thanks for that um no I'm not
pregnant I actually lost my uterus to
cancer last year and um this is what
women of my age look like so if it is
offensive to you
that is
unfortunate think about the emails that
you
sent now Leslie's response clearly
striking a nerve with many it's been
viewed millions of Times online it's had
names like Michelle feifer Jam Lee
Curtis showing their support and Leslie
Horton joins us now here on the morning
show Les always good to see you uh did
you immediately upon opening that email
did you know that you wanted to call out
that viewer oh absolutely not I opened
the email he was a he it's a he I will
tell you that it it is a he I won't uh
be releasing his name uh he has been
sending me emails for a few years now
and all of them are nasty and you just
sort of um ignore them and you move on
and um and say whatever all of us in
this business get those nasty emails I
opened that email that morning we were
in our show here at Global Calgary and I
just
thought really put it aside went uh into
Studio to do my traffic report and these
words just started coming out of my
mouth did I rehearse them no did I plan
them no would did I plan to take
somebody down so to speak no absolutely
not I just thought I get to draw a line
when someone says something
inappropriate to me and the point of
that email that he sent that day was to
shame me to embarrass me to humiliate me
and to make me feel bad about myself and
guess what no one else gets to do that I
say no this is my line and and if that
is going to make you feel better or if
that's going to somehow Elevate you then
I'm going to encourage you to look at
yourself so I those words came out of my
mouth I'm glad they were coherent they
weren't planned but they apparently
struck a nerve they sure did I'm so glad
you did that as are others the support
you have received has been amazing not
surprising at all you're very much loved
we love you so much uh I'm curious
though
what this and the reaction what it has
all meant to you that the community that
the Greater Community and we mentioned
Jam Lee Curtis posting your comments
your your address to him on on her page
on her wall what has this response meant
to you I think it shown me that we
really really need to have some
conversations don't we I have heard from
women who have said thank you for
speaking what I do not have the courage
to speak and I think wow that's a key we
all have the courage to speak up I'm
just a mom in Calgary doing you know TV
hosting but I have a line and if you are
going to reach out with inappropriate
words aimed at hurting shaming and
humiliating I get to say no you may not
you may not that's my line and we all
have have that line and I think some of
us maybe have not felt that we could use
our voice as women age I'm 59 I'm 59 60
is coming up girls trip woo I'm 59 as we
age we get more comfortable in our skin
and and a as our bodies change we just
have to accept that we just have to
accept that we get more comfortable in
our skin maybe we get more courageous
maybe we build our eles good networks of
support so that we can say and every one
of us has a right to say no you may not
speak to me that way I have a teenage
daughter and we've done lots of
conversations about standing up for
yourself and I have seen her do it we
all need to feel empowered to do that
because no one can bring you down unless
you let them we spend so much time
fighting ourselves let's just stop that
be your own cheerleader right you have
to be your own cheerleader and you have
to stand up for yourself and I had a
moment where I stood up for myself and
it just struck a cord I think mhm well
listen good on you for that Les and I'm
going to Echo what car just said and so
many others listen I've been to Calgary
the last couple of years and seen
firsthand the love and quite frankly the
ad admiration that calgarians in
particular have for this uh woman who is
an institution in this uh City that
doesn't mean I'm forgiving you for the
Cricut dogs at the Stampede Fairgrounds
last year I still have Cricket feet in
my teeth I think we're going have to do
that again Caroline you need to come out
and join us at Stampede we got a good
time to show you well um I'm hoping I
get an invite to the 60th girls trip
that's what I uh that's what I want to
do right and you know what there's
nothing wrong with being 59 and being on
TV I've heard from people like you are
way too old and fat and frumpy to be on
TV oh I'm sorry were there not 59y old
women in the community that we should be
reflecting yeah I think there are we're
here and we have voices so don't make
yourself small ladies make yourself big
and tall yes sending you our love and
support Les thank you so much good to
see you this morning